what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are going to be talking about the
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
today and who better to have on the show
for that than dr. Seth Shostak is that a
legitimate question because I could give
you some suggestions great to be there
thank you for coming out of the show
this is I think maybe the fourth time
that we've sat down together across the
different productions that we've done
over the last two years something like
that and I love hanging out with you
because you're both very intelligent and
hilarious and I love that about you
so we're gonna be yeah yeah what do you
have to say I was gonna say anything I
say that refers to the truth of the
matter will be disillusioning for you so
I want Seth has an incredible background
he spent 29 years at SETI the search
fresh structural intelligence that's
located right down here in Mountain View
in California in the Bay Area and I
think a lot of times people come here as
like engineers that are fresh to the Bay
Area and they're like what do you mean
NASA Ames is here and Cestius here and
all these different you know there's
like these beautiful organizations here
that have been here for decades that are
working on incredible progress yeah it
is it is remarkable because the Silicon
Valley which is indeed what you're
talking about here I mean if you if
you'd showed up 50 years ago in the
Silicon Valley you'd say this is a great
place for growing fruit and nuts and
things like that and now suddenly it's
all high-tech
that's that's largely Stanford
University actually yeah yes Stanford's
been a major role in that development
down there Paul so Berkeley has been
across the bay as well and and okay so
also 17 years as a host of big-picture
science no I don't think it's 17 but at
least 10 or 12 that's what that's what I
do that's what I read for about you
since 2002 listen you know I don't all
right uh I'll argue with you but okay
yeah it's been a long time so a week
though helping people see the big
picture about science in different
multi-discipline areas well it's not
just space yeah no that's right yeah if
we restricted ourselves to astronomy or
space and there are shows that do that
of course yeah but you know you've sort
of run out of interest
material after three weeks whereas if
you open it up to all science right then
you can go into things like you know
neuroscience or biology or the behavior
of animals or are we inventing our
successors or any of this other stuff
all of which is quite interesting so you
don't have to be a specialist in your
interest to listen to this show yeah and
generalists also have a very
brett-brett understanding of reality and
I really like that a lot it makes for
more Polymathic conversations they know
a little about about everything
alright so also for time author as well
which is exciting you working you mean
books yeah yeah yeah that's yeah well
one of them was a textbook and that was
I I had a collaborator with that Jeff
Bennett and he did most of the work to
be honest he's a very accomplished at
that did they have pitchers do your
books have pictures all my books had
pictures all sets books have pictures
they do they do they're not necessarily
good pictures but the problem with
pictures in books is not the pictures
it's the fact that it's expensive to
make pictures in printed books now you
know with the advent of electronic
publishing or you do you know then it
doesn't cost anything but for a real
printed book pictures are expensive
particularly if you want them to be high
resolution so you need good paper you
want them in color now you need good
paper and a propriety of a printing
press they can print clearly and yeah
that's all a technical and economic
matter so the pictures are just
something that are there to you know
amuse the reader occasionally
let's talk about the search for
structural intelligence in the most
multidisciplinary as well as timeline
multi-decade process we are here in
Silicon Valley we've seen technology
impact the SETI in so many incredible
ways we now have radio telescopes there
are multiple hundreds of meters in
diameter and that enables us to really
listen to the universe we now take
artificial intelligence algorithms that
are able to parse all of that
information and and that's like
brand-new oh this this is brand-new
cutting-edge stuff so it's been
huge development over time and we used
to think that it was much easier to
think that we were alone and now Kepler
and Tessa's up and now it's much less
likely that we're alone so this is these
are all extremely exciting discoveries
for us and uncover so why don't you
unpack for us a little bit about what
you've really been seeing over the last
40 years well there have been two major
developers first off the question of is
there any life out there I agree with
you I mean it would be remarkable if
there weren't because there's just so
much real estate I mean what is it
Douglas Adams said space is big really
big he said something like that
well of course it is and something that
we've you know we've learned in the past
two dozen years is that there are
trillion planets in the Milky Way that's
trillion with a T that's the Milky Way
galaxy there truly and other galaxies
that's a lot of real estate if it's all
sterile except for earth you gotta say
that's disappointing but not only
disappointing it makes us very special
in y'all always ought to be a little bit
skeptical about being special it's a
waste of space yeah you know that's kind
of a film I don't know but I think that
the big the big changes in the past two
dozen years again let me let me put it
that way
in this whole field of okay there's a
lot of real estate is there any of it
that's inhabited either by simple
organisms microbes or something or by
you know Klingon something like that the
changes have been won in astronomy now
that we know that there are planets
that's new you know when I was a kid we
didn't know whether the planets around
other stars
I mean you figured maybe there were but
figuring maybe there are isn't the same
as knowing and the other thing is the
equipment that you've just been
describing that the ability to eavesdrop
for example on radio signals from
another world has gotten enormous ly
better in the past 20 years yeah that's
huge I like how you start it from the
big-picture perspective right away so
these hundreds of billions of stars in
just our galaxy and every star is
guaranteed to have at least one planet
now we're guaranteed I mean you know you
can get your money back on some of the
but yeah most of them do that point is
those are rogue those rogue ones that
are just hanging out there maybe more
planets and aren't attached to stars and
then are yeah it could very well be ok
so then another interesting point that
we really like talking about as we take
this big picture perspective also is
that so two-thirds of all stars are
single star systems
but then one-third of stars at least in
our galaxy are binary star systems or
two stars orbiting each other or
multiple star systems three stars or
four stars orbiting each other which
that in itself is also very mind-blowing
how cool it would have been to evolve
around a in a different solar system
with different planets and different
amounts of stars a different mass of
planet with different gravitational pull
so all that stuff these are like little
variables to calculate yeah looks like
the neighborhood you grow up in I mean
you know they're not all the same let's
face it and and it's true that you know
in the universe roughly half of all
stars are multiple stars right and you
have two star systems or the binary
those are very common three star systems
even four star system I mean it's like
the Michelin Guide for restaurants right
and when you get up to four stars that
aren't many the plenty one star in two
stars so yeah it would be like it's like
that scene with Luke Skywalker right in
Star Wars or he comes out of whatever
Hut it is that he's living in and he
sees two stars in this guy I mean we
could have been born in a system like
that it looks like it would work in
terms of having planets that you know
stay in orbit so yeah I mean in the old
days in the old days being like twenty
years good I was going to ask you about
this yeah well we wouldn't point the
antennas in the directions of double
stars if you will or triple stars
because it was thought not if there ever
were any planets they're you know
they're they're orbiting around but then
this star pulls a little more than that
star and they get kicked out so it's not
a stable nest for your chicks but as it
turns out it it can be stable okay so
the tools that were used 20 30 even
years ago what was being conducted back
then now we're talking about
multiple hundred meter telescopes and
radio telescopes and AI algorithms what
was being done 20 30 years ago in
comparison well the first modern setting
Experian that was Frank Drake in 1960
okay so you know that's nearly 60 years
ago now and in 1960 used in antenna in
West Virginia it was a very big Green
Bank West Virginia was built in the 60s
Green Bank 1960 Oh new greenback was
Bill actually in the late 1950s some of
it cool that this was very early day so
yeah so this same tenant was 85 feet in
diameter now that would impress the
neighbors if you put it in your backyard
they probably have you have it removed
but you know for the time it was a
pretty big pretty big antenna and so he
used it but only for a couple of weeks
and he pointed in the direction of a
couple nearby stars tuned in and he
tuned the radio receiver because after
all you don't know where a signal might
be right he tuned it with essentially a
bit of string and a little motor over
here that just sort of turned the knob
on the receiver it was really quite
quite simple so he's only listening to
one channel at a time how does one
adjust a radio telescope to to go for
just one channel or one piece of the
radio frequency well that's in the
receiver okay
so the antenna is just aimed at the sky
and there's a you know a an amplifier
he's getting a little technical but at
the point of focus and then that sends
down all this cosmic static and then you
tune it it's just like it's like the
antenna on your roof if you still have
one I don't mean roof but antenna if you
still have an antenna on your roof right
it's picking up all the stuff that's out
there floating through the ether as it
were but then you have a TV set or a
radio or something connected to that
antenna and you tune a particular part
of the radio spectrum so that's waved
uh-huh and then this sort of the
technology itself from if the years ago
that was more of Mille to move and
follow the star even back then it was
put on a motor system so that it could
well telescopes are able to do that
otherwise I mean essentially all because
otherwise you have a kind of limited
instrument now having said that you know
the biggest antenna in the world and you
you're making kind of a subtle reference
to it earlier is what's called the fast
f8s tea in China it's a convoluted
acronym but anyhow it's what is it five
hundred meters in diameter right the
fifteen hundred feet is like a you know
it's more than a quarter a mile across
that's a big thing yeah but you can't
sort of point it either here or there
somewhere else
it's just aimed straight up but you can
move the receiver around a little bit
and that allows you to look here there
you know and of course the Earth rotates
something that many people have noticed
and it's flat yes that simplifies the
geometry mom and there's kids watching
this show here for the first time folks
this flat what do you do then with a
small let's say 30 meter radio telescope
versus a 500 meter radio telescope how
does that change the your ability to
live well it's a bigger bucket you know
it's like collecting rainwater if you
will if you know you really want to have
enough water to you know boil an egg
here's something you're having a really
small bucket might not do it for you
right so having a bigger bucket gets you
more of the water in the case of a radio
antenna you're able to pick up fainter
signals all of which means something
very simple you ET might be broadcasting
something out there but if you don't
have enough sensitivity if you don't
have a big enough bucket you might not
pick up the signal don't you know it
improves the chances that you'll find
something okay so that is so let's let's
stay a little bit longer with though
with radio telescopes because then
there's also photometry as well which is
these are different sort of methods of
understanding the cosmos so on on radio
telescopes we're typically we're trying
to hear their radio waves is what we're
trying to do yeah we're trying to pick
up their transmitters their transmitters
I mean it's just like you know what you
do it on when you turn on your radio if
you turn on your
you know more people should turn on
their radios but yes it's exactly yet I
mean if they're mean if this was the big
insight actually and this was done even
before that first experiment this was
done in 1959 that's a long time ago now
and it was just a couple of physicists I
think they were at Cornell at the time
but I'm not hundred percent sure where
they were actually working but in any
case they said look let's consider a
simple thought experiment take the
world's biggest radar radar transmitter
here those are powerful transmitters
okay put it here and over here put the
world's biggest receiving antenna and
have the transmitter aim at the
receiving antenna okay can you pick up
the radar with this with you of course
you can pick it on him I know moving a
little farther apart can you still pick
it up yeah yeah how far apart can you
put these two things and still be able
to pick it up and it turned out it's a
simple calculation by the way that it
was light-years light-years so was
distances that are comparable to the
distances between the stars so if they
realized right away and wrote a paper
about was that you know even in 1959
which was you know 60 years after
Marconi even then we had technology that
would allow you to send information from
one star system to another so maybe it
pays to listen to the sky come so maybe
somebody's doing this and so then the
the general ideas that we think that
planets orbiting stars once evolution
evolves there and intelligence evolves
there that they would then begin
transmitting signals across the cosmos
that we can then receive and understand
where they are who they are
potentially yeah that's right and that's
actually you know might think oh that's
pretty obvious of course they're gonna
do that it's like saying all right look
let's assume that some intelligent
species evolves on some other planet are
they ever gonna invent the wheel I don't
know Bob what are you thinking they're
getting about the wheel maybe they won't
invent the wheel well probably they'll
invent the wheel eventually because it
turns out the wheels pretty useful for
getting around almost any kind of
terrain right yeah all right so well do
you think they'll invent radio well if
they develop any sort of science
eventually they'll develop radio right I
mean it's only you know 2,500 years
between
Aristotle and Marconi right that's all
it is that isn't very long compared to
the history of the universe so you
assume yeah they've invented radio and
maybe they're using it to send messages
to colonies in space or their equivalent
to the Starship Enterprise or maybe
they're just trying to get in touch with
somebody else out there you don't know
you don't know any of that but you can
say if they have science maybe they're
also using this way of communicating
I like how you made it clear that if the
intelligence evolves that they're likely
gonna hit some milestones like wheels
and radio and then that makes sense to
look for that now
SETI is mostly using the Allen telescope
array and we have some cool photos of
the Allen telescope array we're trying a
TA or the ATA one yeah a ta ta-a ta one
both are really cool one of them is like
an aerial view and then the other one is
is the view with here's that here's the
aerial one yeah it's on the so much of
it has been censored as you can see
justifiably
like that so this is 42 radio telescopes
yes and this is in the north east part
of California that's correct it's a it
is called the Allen telescope array I
might point this out it I know that it
sounds like a tribute to you a big
donation for me if we can double it in
size and call it the Allen telescope
array and it would be an inside bit of
knowledge that it's named after you but
at the moment this is named after Paul
Allen and because he gave the money to
get this thing started the idea is to
build hundreds of these antennas by the
way so this is just a start
no no what's the difference between
having 40 to smaller radio telescopes
versus having a 100 to 300 meter
diameter well if they can do different
things but the real advantage is it's a
lot cheaper for any giving collecting
area you know how big is the bucket how
much rain can it collect to build lots
of small little buckets that didn't work
if you will as one big bucket then it is
to build one big bucket
oh it's cheaper it's cheaper because I
mean you could
about if you want just a little bit of
simple arithmetic have you taken antenna
and you make it twice as big across then
the collecting area you know how much
how much rain that buckets gonna get
goes as pi r-squared goes as the square
but the amount of metal you need is you
know gonna go up as the cube because you
need it twice as white Weiss's deep and
twice as high sometimes 2 times 2 is 8
times more expensive but only four times
more collecting area all right
this is kind of a tedious little
argument but all it's saying is that
it's gonna be a lot cheaper to make lots
of small ones there are other advantages
to doing that but they're even more
technical can they all be tuned to
listen to different yeah they work as a
team they work as a team they do okay
and and this is on the we're looking at
below what on what nanometer are we
talking about from radio waves again
well in terms of the frequency this
instrument goes between 1000 mega mega
Hertz and about 15,000 mega Hertz so
these are wavelengths that are kind of
like that it's it's you know high
frequency radar frequencies yeah okay
yeah but then that's that's completely
opposite from the from the gamma and
x-ray oh it's way out in the other side
yeah it's not a light telescope when
people think of telescopes they think of
something with lenses and mirrors and
things like that that's very much
shorter wavelength your higher frequency
but you know it's still like radio waves
of just light but not the light you can
see with your eyes you need something
yeah okay so then you guys so this is
interesting because you were telling me
SETI ISM well using the Allen telescope
array let's show the other one the other
image is also really cool yeah not to us
of me so so so this is a good shot as
well of that got lost in translation
yeah there you go that's better so this
is good because you have a like a long
exposure shot of them at night looks
really beautiful now you were telling me
earlier that SETI is mostly using a
telescope array but you're not using
like Arecibo in Puerto Rico and
Greenbank you're not using these other
radio telescopes what's is there like a
long line or like what's the deal with
well the deal is
it's very prosaic deal it's called money
right this is what we use and I say we
that's the SETI Institute in Mountain
View
but there's another SETI experiment here
in the Bay Area called breakthrough
listen yes and they're over at Berkeley
and they have money which we don't have
we have very little money we're running
on donations here but Berkeley got a big
donation and as a consequence they can
you know just rent time on big antennas
oh this is ours actually so we get to
use this 12 hours a day at least they
rent time on antennas that can be bigger
than these in Green Bank West Virginia
in Australia Parkes Australia and for
that matter Arecibo down in Puerto Rico
got it so it's about the amount of money
that has to be spent to read the time on
themselves right we own these guys yes
but nonetheless you have maintenance and
all that whereas they are renting time
but on bigger instruments you're on a
very low budget under 10 million a year
is that right oh it concedes under 1
million a year at this point it's under
1 million a year prefer the SETI
Institute SETI program yes no it's
strictly limited by money
well that's because of disclosure that's
so unfortunate are just pushing some of
the you know the billions of dollars
that we have for science as the United
States towards SETI would be such a
important idea well it is and it's kind
of a puzzle in a way that why is it that
you know for example the Space Agency's
NASA in particularly spends hundreds of
millions of dollars to send probes to
Mars also eventually to look for life
but of course if you find life on Mars
and I you know there's a good chance you
will eventually it'll be microbial life
or maybe dead life but did you know but
it's gonna be single celled organisms
yeah not gonna be more complex than that
or complicated or bigger
it couldn't be multicellular well I mean
it could be you know multicellular life
took a long time to arise here on earth
and but earth had oceans for the last
four and a half billion years Mars does
not we all know what store
as core we don't yeah we don't it could
be that their underground reservoirs of
water but in any case but we spend
hundreds of millions of dollars doing
that and there's no government money
spent doing this and you might think
well gosh darn it
I mean we're looking for intelligent
life here the kind of things you see in
the movies and on TV yeah that sounds a
little more interesting than finding
microbes yeah but on the I am are you
are you are you looking at the nearest
star systems
what are you focused on and what were
you focused on twenty years ago ten
years ago now in terms of where are you
pointing yeah I mean you gotta make it
you gotta make a guess in the end your
best guess is - where - look it's sort
of like you know somebody drops you off
enough South Pacific island says you
know they're coming some buried treasure
here here take this shovel and shovel it
alright so you you know easy well I
don't know I think it'd probably be
buried here on the beach right so you
start digging some holes in the beam
somebody else says well now maybe not on
the beach because you got all the water
coming in and it probably wash away any
buried treasure maybe you ought to look
inland right nobody knows but it's true
that we tend to look at nearby star
systems because you know if there are
any planets around those star systems
that are broadcasting signals well the
signals would be stronger strong so and
we're talking like 25 or a thousand
light-years away something like that so
yeah somewhere in that range would be
about right on the other hand we were
also choosing specific kinds of star
systems - these days we're looking at
the smaller stars because they're good
reasons to think that they may have read
higher percentage of red dwarfs they may
have a higher percentage of planets that
are suitable for life so you know I want
to maximize your bed it's like going to
go into Vegas right that's what I was
asking yeah yeah how do you pick so okay
so red dwarf so these are about
one-tenth the size of our star some are
but I mean they're they're planting red
dwarfs that are maybe half the diameter
of the Sun okay okay but half the
diameter it isn't that they're just half
as bright you know it's it's it's like
people think difference decided I mean
any differences in the IQ
but half the size means that they're
much much dimmer and on the one hand you
can say well that doesn't sound good
it's also comparable to the radio
telescope in the metal example yes yeah
it's because the smaller study if you
really care about this but the smaller
stars you know they're not as hot in the
center because you know they don't weigh
as much a and because they're not as hot
their nuclear engines don't run as
quickly so they don't provide a lot a
lot of light right how is it that the
planets orbiting them have a higher
propensity well because they seem to
have a lot of planets and a lot of
planets that are close to the star where
it's gonna be you know warm enough if
you will that they can have some sort of
life so yeah that they might be a better
bet for life one doesn't know but there
is one thing that they do have that the
other kinds of stars don't have and that
is because there's there's so dim right
it sounds like a lot of my relatives
they're so dim that they don't run out
of fuel right away right the sun's gonna
you know it's got another five billion
years I mean you got to sell your real
estate before another five billion years
because the sun's gonna die right but
these stars they last for a hundred
billion years so that means that every
year old red dwarfs last longer Oh much
longer huh and that means that every red
dwarfs avaible bad news you know they're
not necessarily more stable but they
they just burned it a lower flame and at
a lower flame it's like a maybe a
Volkswagen Beetle right I mean it has a
really small engine so can go a long way
on a tank is something like that so so
on average they're very very much older
every red star a red dwarf star that was
ever born in the universe I mean it's
still alive that they burn away so there
that are stars well more than half of
them are older than the Sun do so maybe
being older is a better deal if you're
looking for et because there's been more
times I for that life to have evolved as
well okay and then those planets
orbiting that those red dwarfs are
likely much smaller than Earth as well
to have not necessarily the playoffs
don't need to be smaller I mean it gotta
have some jupiter-sized planets I mean
we found planning a planets around red
dwarfs and they're not all small but
could a jupiter-sized played at orbiting
a red dwarf evolve life
well jupiter-sized planets tend to be
like
Jupiter what disadvantages of a big
planets that they tend to be gas balls
instead of little rocky hard you know
billiard ball planets like you you
normally think about I mean you you
could try moving to Jupiter Allen but
you know you wouldn't be happy with a
lifestyle I mean it's not clear that
there's any surface on Jupiter right you
could you rock it and you can't just
sort of land on this earth there's no
service when you look at Jupiter you're
looking at the weather right it's all
gasp did Juno dive into Jupiter yeah
normally they dive right into the Juno I
don't know about you know but you know
right those idea was Saturn and then I
think it was Galileo Galileo Galileo but
yeah I mean you know you send it down in
there and did we get a signal back on
the way in for a while and then we saw
what in there wasn't no there's no land
we think it's just gas no there's no way
well there may be oh that nobody knows
for sure but certainly for the first
10,000 miles it's it's old gas okay and
it by the way it's not all that likable
gas it's you know methane ammonia
probably neon and but it's getting
hotter as you go in that's yeah yeah yes
eventually you vaporize you that's
that's what happened to it the
spacecraft just became part of Jupiter's
atmosphere we are what a fate we already
polluted Jupiter with our own space job
that's right that's right
Jupiter gets polluted all the time by
asteroid so that's right that's right
okay so all right so you're looking at
different patches of the sky that you
think are most likely to give us some
sort of signs of intelligence hopefully
and and then as you're using the Allen
telescope array for this you're now
having young people that are helping you
that are you know fluent in machine
learning and fluent in artificial
intelligence and to be able to parse
these long streams of of listening and
try and find the potentials of when we
get a signal well we do try this I mean
I don't know where those those armies of
young people I want to work on this are
willing to take
1 million a year budget yeah I don't
know maybe maybe they you say there's
somebody else's office there not mine
but but what we you we do do I mean
you're correct we're trying to apply
artificial intelligence to this right
because we just don't have the money to
pay for organic intelligence find on the
streets of Mountain View yeah so but
also for another reason I mean
artificial intelligence there's a lot of
bravado about artificial intelligence
but the advantage of it is that it can
look for any kind of unusual signals it
isn't restricted to things that are
precooked in the software where you say
look look for a narrowband signal that
has these characteristics for example
right the artificial intelligence will
say well I'm just going to look for
everything right it's like looking for
critters in in Africa you could build
some sort of device that's gonna find
anything that has a long nose that can
pick up peanuts
ok maybe you'll find something maybe you
won't but if you had AI then you just
look for anything that moves around it
has two eyes or something like that ok
so now you're able to look a little bit
more broad that's the idea we haven't we
haven't implemented all this artificial
intelligence yet that there's early days
but anybody who pays attention to
technology knows that artificial
artificial intelligence is on the March
yeah and it's probably coming for us
actually but that aside you know the the
equipment used for this kind of searches
rapidly moving to a AI techniques and
for that matter you know the aliens
themselves may just be AI yeah ok so
it's looking like in the next couple of
years that we have we we just thought we
talked a lot about radio telescopes and
we and which is what SETI does but then
there's also photometry and telescopes
like on the ground that are looking at
the stars and have been taking in as
buckets they're light and then and then
taking that light and then processing it
hopefully for little dips to see if the
planets orbiting it or not and then
there's also the ones that go
up in the orbit like Hubble and Kepler
that have been looking at at the stars
to find little to not only image them
over long periods of time but also to
hopefully find those little dips now we
have tests up there as well so okay so
as we're now moving towards radio
telescopes light telescopes James Webb
is coming up as well after that what are
you most in artificial intelligence now
being applied what are you most seeing
in the next decade or so as where yeah
what do you think well there's some
obvious to me what you're asking is what
kind of techniques do I see coming down
the pike that can either speed up the
search or just find something right away
and of course nobody knows you know
what'll work until it works we're
certainly looking at what are what
you've been describing here sort of
optical telescopes in other words
instead of looking for radio waves let's
look for flashing lights in the sky or
something like that and that's a good
thing to do flashing now are you seeing
flashing lights in the sky where you are
running it wasn't done what I saw it
wasn't a flashing light and this is this
is the best description I can give it to
you it looked like something came into
the atmosphere our earth atmosphere real
quick did would it have to do and then
bounced out and that changed my life
forever
you heard it here okay
were you abducted or something I know I
don't believe I was abducted if I was I
certainly don't remember
I think it was they they hit me with
that laser beam there doc yeah well they
may have done hey I mean it could be I
don't know why they've I mean no offense
but it's not a you disagree you know
we're gonna spend 20 trillion galactic
cruzeiro's bill this giant spacecraft
and go that little yellow star 427
light-years away find the blue planet
around it and go down and zap Ron okay
maybe they maybe they vote for that but
maybe they don't vote for it but there
might be
using lasers to signal that that's a
legitimate thing something else you
could look for I've become a bit more of
a fan of this approach is say you know
forget about any signals they might be
making signals they might not be making
signals I figure they probably are but
they might not be aiming those signals
in our direction that's a that's a
trickier point but maybe they if they're
really advanced they're doing some
really advanced stuff they're building
something big right if you wanted to
find no signatures
yeah tech no signature it's like if
there were Martians you know they're
sitting around thinking well what are we
gonna do this week and I'll but he says
Martians anymore
Martians god that's like 50 stuff yeah I
didn't mean Martian sign Venusian no
whatever it is it's all top secret it's
a you know keep spending your money this
is the thing Mars has become top secret
this will be be of some interest to many
of my colleagues who make a modest
living studying Mars okay but suppose
you were on Mars just leaving aside the
question of whether anybody would be but
if you were on Mars so you wanted to
find out if there was any intelligent
life on Earth you know you could build
some big antennas and just
eavesdrop on reality television or you
could build some big optical telescopes
and just look for freeway interchanges
which are pretty big things and you
could you could see them from Mars with
a big enough telescope so and that
doesn't require that we be many signals
to them they just find stuff that we
built and that's just sitting there so
that's another approach to finding
intelligent life elsewhere okay so where
you described optical telescopes we
found exoplanets and large quantities we
are at what four thousand yea 3,500
something and how many of those are
earth-like well we don't know how many
are really earth like we know what
fraction of them are roughly the same
size of the earth that's maybe a third
or a fourth and a third and that but
most of those aren't the wrong distance
from their star either they're too hot
you know in all the water will boil away
the oceans boil away are they're so far
out that all the oceans freeze the the
number that are sort of in what's called
a habit of
zone yeah any kind of a misnomer but
whatever you know it's on the order of
50 maybe a hundred we don't know but
that's not the interesting thing the
interesting thing is like I can tell
from your expression that you know it's
not the interesting thing that was only
one patch of star sky 150 well uh what's
really relevant is what fraction of
stars have a planet that might be
interesting and and that might be 20
percent to 20 percent that's a lot and
that's the Drake Equation that got us to
that
well the Drake Equation sort of
stipulated that the problem it never
gave us the answer the Drake Equation
came without the back of the book or you
could look up the answers yeah yeah okay
so now that we that now that we think we
postulate K about one out of every five
stars is gonna have an earth-like planet
in this habitable zone we found about
3,500 or so these exoplanets with Kepler
now Tess is up Tess is now looking at
star systems that are near Earth and
focusing on just those star systems and
then it's identifying really good
potentials for a James Webb when James
Webb telescope goes up hopefully in two
years and so is what yeah go ahead no I
was okay
just as owning out yeah yeah I did is
it's a lot of this you guys already like
you know you guys already talked about I
just so now but so what so what about
the what about what's going on in these
next couple of years like where are we
where are we heading with this
technology what do you see you know
that's a bit like asking Chris Columbus
you know it's been I don't know three
weeks since you're left Spain and all
you found is water you know how do you
see the future or water maybe it's just
gonna be more while hopefully landed
yeah at some point am you're gonna get
tired of just eating water so so you're
asking me to speculate and what might be
coming down that down
you know across the horizon in the near
term obviously we're going to be you
know getting better instruments and in
speeding up the search and stuff like
that yeah but in terms of the science I
mean the observational science yeah
we're gonna find more planets with with
tests we're gonna find planets around
the nearest stars and with James Webb
telescope or other very big telescopes
that are being built now yeah we might
be able to sort of examine the
atmospheres of those plants in other
words what's in the air of those planets
and you know if it's just carbon dioxide
or again you say well that's like the
atmosphere of Venus or Mars not very
interesting but if you found oxygen you
would say you know I don't know Ralph
but oxygen that sounds like there's some
photosynthesis there yeah so that would
allow you to find that or methane
methane is produced by you know cows and
pigs and stuff like that so and bacteria
and this is a bio signature versus like
techno techno signature could be
something like a big Dyson Sphere that's
right encompassing the star and
harvesting for energy bio signatures
oxygen having photo signature could be
you know it doesn't have to be smart
life to produce bio signatures right the
methane in the atmosphere this room here
is presumably produced by cows and and
pigs and so you might be able to find
pigs in space without you know on a
planet where there's nothing intelligent
although I'm told the pigs are pretty
intelligent but you could find pigs in
space by finding the methane in the
atmosphere don't need to see the pigs
and then okay now we're also approaching
this space economy era
thank goodness for companies like SpaceX
that have really taken it taking on the
initiative with the Entrepreneurship
rather than just waiting for the
governmental agencies to kind of to do
it themselves but so now we have this
space economy that's launching forward
now it's easier for us to launch things
like small satellites into space it's
easier for us to resupply the
International Space Station so this is
all very good stuff so where do you see
that sort of space economy moving
forward well I mean obviously that's you
know space tourism is one of the
earliest
industries to take advantage of space
the other is space mining where you can
you know go into space and you go grab
an asteroid and you know asteroids have
a lot of interesting stuff like platinum
and but they actually the most
commercially interesting stuff in an
astro he's probably the water I think
water
yeah well water because you need water
if you're gonna have people in space
right you need to have the water and
water it's pretty cheap here on earth
but it was but what is it 65 pounds per
cubic foot something like that oh that's
heavy it's heavy man and it is heavy and
65 pounds that's build a rocket it has
to lift up all the water yeah it's very
expensive transport costs so you know so
if you can get it in space where you
don't have to lift it up with a rocket
that's a good thing that's a good place
and as far as tourism yeah what would
you pay to go into orbit for the weekend
there was a guy who's in the hotel
business and he looked into this and he
actually did marketing research and you
know he figured a bunch of space
habitats and people would be rocketed up
there for half a million dollars of
space hotels and apparently there is a
market mostly driven by the idea of
waitlist sex that was the thing oh yeah
weightless sex yeah the sex and also
just the idea of your back and hips just
decompressing as well we just world we
always have this gravity pushing down on
us so this is in connection with your
experience in there yeah it is zero
gravity zero gravity well not yet but
I've thought about building a chamber
here eventually when I'm the Trinian's
that is so it would be so great to
experiment with that we a weightless sex
is also very interesting that's our
timer thank you Ron I'll flip this one
over I still have a couple questions I
want to make yeah okay well I won't
elaborate on that tub out of the way
with sex but this there's a book about
it by the way it's it's essentially a
Velcro handbook if you want to know oh
just tell me okay so space tourism was
that's a really good answer and I and I
really hope to see us move forward with
going to the moon again and putting some
habitats they're going to Mars figuring
out how to optimize Terra formation of
Mars and you know making us an
interplanetary species it's very
exciting stuff so now I have a question
for you because it seems as though an
answer to the Fermi paradox which I
think we got into a little small like
Twitter conversation about with like
Natalie Battaglia and David Grinspoon
and stuff which are also very close
friends that we fo said we'd love them
so much that is it is it there's two
things here I want to hear your thoughts
it is it is it potentially possible that
the reason why we're not hearing from
other civilizations out there is because
the sheer difficulty of intelligence to
figure out how to cooperate and
therefore make things like artificial
intelligence that ends up potentially
exterminating them or war or whatever it
may be that well I'm not quite sure what
you're asking there maybe it's is it
very likely that just cuz you have some
planet with all sorts of life on it you
know the creepy crawlers plants whatever
that it's ever going to produce
something that's clever enough to build
a radio transmitter for example is it
good ever gonna develop intelligence
because I just mean life on Earth for
four billion years like dinosaurs if
they didn't get wiped out probably still
would've roamed the dinosaurs would have
been here in San Francisco anyplace the
advantages you could find a parking spot
the disadvantage is the only people you
could visit we're dinosaur then that's a
good and and you know you could say all
the dinosaurs would surely have evolved
into something clever but they had 150
million years did do that and they did
not so yep so it's not clear nature is
not necessarily interested in two birds
how do you do it there's rumors that the
dinosaurs are birds now so yeah birds
are well dinosaurs a person actually
it's more correct to say that birds are
dinosaurs now you talk to any expert on
dinosaurs and they would tell you birds
are not like dinosaurs they're not
simply the descendants of dinosaurs they
are dinosaurs okay so if you like you
know Kentucky Fried Chicken
which I'm by the way do you like eating
dinosaurs ok fine but they're not really
running the planet anymore you may think
the birds are running the planet I know
Alfred had a Hitchcock kid but in fact
yes it's not clear that give give nature
hundreds of millions of years yeah it's
ever gonna produce intelligence yes
that's it that's a very controversial
point okay so that's the that's that
first point and then the second point is
even if it does evolve intelligence
kindom advanced chimpanzees figure out
how to collaborate instead of kill each
other well yeah I mean that might never
figure out you know geometry or calculus
or electronics or a radio technology I
mean that the chimps have been very poor
at that or if they do they wipe
themselves out
yeah the chimps that doesn't seem to be
the problem with the chimps and wiping
them cells out so much but yeah this is
just a controversial point and nobody
knows the answer because we only have
one example that's here on earth okay
here it worked but here uh so far yeah
we're sure no I'm optimistic alan i'm
not building a bomb i'm not i'm
optimistic too but I'm also realistic
and I see us without a parent building
artificial intelligence and I'm
definitely wanting to just have a deeper
conversation with society about it and
there's a geopolitical race for it as
well so okay here here here's and here's
just another thought free for you again
let me replace my batteries my battery
yeah all right out here okay how is it
do you think that this has now become
more and more of something that I think
could be an answer to the Fermi paradox
as well which is that civilizations
become so advanced that they go quiet
because they all go into either virtual
realities or they all go into other
designed worlds that they want to go and
experiment and they can go virtually
transfer virtually travel the cosmos
rather than have to actually build the
massive spaceships to do so so maybe
they just go quiet then yeah I can't
argue against that I mean that's that's
quite possible there was a a short story
by Stanislav LEM called
Gollum Gollum 14 something like that and
it was exactly the deal the the
Department of Defense built this
thinking machine right the big computer
and for defense purposes and you know
they they use this thing to whatever
develop strategies and then they had it
devise a better machine than it was they
built that right and it's helping out
the DoD there and then they build a
third machine this one is so competent
so capable that it stops talking to them
it gets tired of working for the
Department of Defense right and you know
and in fact it doesn't have any
communication whatsoever with the humans
that built this time thing right it's
just sitting there humming and the only
time it'll you know wake up from the
point of view somebody's standing around
it is if you try and pull the plug out
or turn the switch off is that so it
will defend that but otherwise it has
nothing to do with you it's doing
something it's sitting in there it's
humming and maybe that is exactly what
the machines would do they would sit
there maybe play freecell or run
Ancestors similar you know simulation
whatever they do but it may not involve
you it's just like you know I coexist
with the the bugs in my backyard the
ants or whatever yeah right but I don't
have much to do with them quite frankly
that's right I don't go out every
morning say hey good morning ants I got
a few one-liners for you yep yep so I
think that that may be a something to
heavily consider as we contemplate the
quietness of the cosmos and potentially
where we head in the next couple of
decades ourselves in that same direction
of just yeah sure we'll might aim to
terraform Mars but I can go live in a
full 3d reality of Mars without even
going in terror for exactly and and
maybe that's maybe that's our future is
just to sit around with goggles on and
you know enjoy a better kind of life hey
I don't know yeah I hope to make the
real world better and the anniversary
well I mean you're still an idealist I'm
personally I'm willing to settle for the
synthetic soul okay I enjoy Las Vegas -
OH
think Seth okay this this question is
really important to me I wonder what
your thoughts are about it I've
definitely been experiencing a lot more
thoughts around if consciousness is
localized in this human body or not do
you think that it is I do but you think
it's localized here yeah I'd like to
think there was something better there
was something meta about my
consciousness yeah also these fried
chicken - I mean Kentucky Fried Chicken
I mean really you know this timer by the
way stopped a long time ago just stops
altogether hey you know the idea that we
have a meta consciousness there were
some sort of human hive mind I think you
can easily disprove it by the divorce
rate I mean yeah I believe they were
working on that the huge I believe
there's something very dark and sinister
among us and that's what it's looking
for and whether the consciousness is
it's nice to maintain that our
consciousness is maintained locally but
they're working to get control of that
so I appreciate what you say we need to
maintain that where our thoughts are our
own and not influenced by this thing
that you're looking for with your
telescopes they'll never reveal
themselves keep spending your money it's
all top secret [ __ ] they're gonna [ __ ]
us no matter what we do bottom line well
not we can't use profanity anymore we
gotta make it a kid we're short word
we're also trying to yeah be educational
afterward which were kids and
universities can watch it all right
hey okay so so cake cause I lost
consciousness consciousness localized in
the human nervous system that's what
you're that's Richard yeah this bottle
okay if my bike that's your take and so
a thought for you I know you are a
scientist meaning you follow the
scientific method and I agree that's
super important and we do it but I think
the scientific method can be augmented
I think it can potentially include other
aspects of the supernatural and the
metaphysical do you experience any of
that essence of maybe spirituality or
things like that yeah I mean you know
everybody has moments in which they
think they're experiencing the
supernatural but on the other hand you
know my radio every now and then it
bursts into a little bit of static I
don't take that as the influence of
other radios in the neighborhood or you
know some sort of supernatural
interference and is a okay there's a
little bit of noise it so I'm not sure
that that I experienced anything that I
would say doesn't fit within the context
of the real world as I see it which is
indeed based on science but maybe I'm
too conservative maybe all sorts of
nifty things are going on I'm just
missing out yet again but Occam's razor
the simplest solution could potentially
it could be which is that it's just
localized here and that it doesn't
matter listen you know Ron over here
thinks that were being manipulated now
that may just go back to you know when
his mom and dad were essentially
controlling his life and so he's used to
a situation in which somebody else more
powerful than he is we're controlling
his life and so we you know we like that
idea that's probably the reason that so
many people think that aliens have come
to earth you know - perhaps abduct them
or do something with them because they
like the idea of more powerful beings
that have taken an interest in them
because that's what the situation was
when asked for any of this [ __ ] but I
don't say that I didn't ask for that I
wasn't asking for anything hold on just
just a quick moment well you don't have
to do there's no need to hold on now
it's up to me to be the powerful being
again whatever it is that you know I
mean I I have to totally dismiss it
don't worry about it you pay no
attention to that man behind the curtain
you clinking clanking car wreck you know
collagenous jerk this is really
important point that Seth is bringing up
because I think to to
often we want to put the power into
something that is something supernatural
something that is greater than us and it
has a lot to do with potentially the we
don't even realize how much of our lives
have to do with our evolutionary lineage
up to this point how little we are in
control and how much more our microbiome
is in control of us than even we are the
microbes that exist in us that have been
around billions of years so that type of
understanding of how we work and how our
moms and dads affected us that type of
understanding the more Polymathic it is
and the more multi-disciplinary it is
the better we can have maybe an
objective scientifically proven way of
understanding things but then also this
sort of potential metaphysical and
supernatural that that might exist would
be great to prove and that is something
that I really care about a lot is
figuring out how to prove that so that
we can augment the scientific method to
include that but also obviously care a
lot about figuring out a ifx and how us
will work with China and all this other
stuff so how do you you know figure out
priorities well you maybe you shouldn't
work on all those problems yes beside
the one you want to work on next
you know the metaphysical approach I
hear you
I think it's appealing but on the other
hand you know science has proven to be
useful because it predicts things it
doesn't say things are sort of random
and now oh something's going to behave a
little differently than it did last week
right when you turn on that TV you kind
of hope that the behavior of electrons
hasn't changed since the last time you
turned it on right is that there's no
metaphysical influence on that it's just
you can write it down at least it is to
there's some level and you know that
science whether there's more to life I I
hope there's more to life but if you
can't sort of demonstrate it with an
experiment then it just sounds like a
good idea but not necessarily what we
would call reality no do you think that
the last couple questions do you think
this is base reality or do you think
this is already a simulation well that's
a good question now as you know there's
this guy Nick Bostrom yeah in the
philosophy department in Oxford
University in the UK and you know he
says there's a 20% chance that we're not
having this conversation
we're just computer code running in some
future computer and I asked him where he
got that 20% number it wasn't very clear
on the answer that but I also asked him
how could I tell
and he said well just look for errors
you know Alan something disappears out
of the chair you don't expect that if he
does that then I can say he wasn't real
this is just a simulation it's like sim
earth
there's a sim Alan right the only
trouble is that anybody who saw the
matrix knows if their mistakes in the
code all they do is they back up the
program fix the error and then run it
again so I never see you just you know
disappear so I I don't think we're a
simulation personally but maybe I'm such
a good simulation that I can't fathom
the possibility that none of this is
real and Seth what do you think is the
most beautiful thing in the world
it's the most beautiful thing in the
world maybe it's the world I don't know
but there be good good starting point
why well our planet is not you know it's
it's got a lot of personality
it's got oceans it's got continents it's
got a life it's got a lot of good stuff
it's a small place compared to most of
the universe but it's it's darn
interesting stars are you know sort of
interesting it stars aren't nearly as
interesting as our planet yeah Seth
Shostak what a pleasure this has been
talking to you well it's been my
pleasure thank you for coming out to the
show and talking to us and I look
forward to exploring more of the cosmos
and evolution and trying to listen to
the stars and other species hopefully
hopefully one day let's go and figure
out how to talk to other people out here
oh you and me both maybe it will bring
us closer together hopefully we don't
need to meet someone outside earth to
realize we're all one tribe here on this
and I wish I could share your optimism
but it's a nice thought thanks everyone
for tuning in we greatly appreciate it
if you guys had a good time there was a
comment below also if you guys had a
good time please do go support SETI go
support big-picture science there
definitely we need your help with that
we need your help with bringing these
conversations to more people subscribe
join the family keep the conversation
going don't just consume this content go
and create with it go make videos go
make blogs go and start your businesses
in space go and execute build into the
world thank you to run our producer
director and thank you everyone for
tuning in and we'll see you soon bye
[Applause]
you
[Music]